一同　礼
こんにちは   今回もやってまいりました
〜今さら人には聞けない〜 人の驚かせ方講座 第82回
今回の担当は私、
マッドマックス・イカリノデス・ロウドノスケ
がお送りいたします。
今日も宜しくお願い致します
今回はこれまでの
人の驚かせ方講座
第1回から第81回までやってきたわけですが
そのまとめにあたる回でございます
人を驚かせることによって、
人生に潤いが生まれ、(わお、OASIS！！)
クオリティ・オブ・ライフ
生活の質の水準が上がるという(※科学的に立証済み)
“驚き”には素晴らしい作用がございます。(※科学的に立証済み)
ぜひこの番組を参考に、
いろんな人を驚かえっｔてみましょう
では、【VTR】どうぞ
ニコッ…
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
どうした？
ワーーッ‼︎‼︎
うわーッ！ワニ ひ〜ぃ
ワニ？
えっ？
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
\ワーーーーッ！！/
ワニッ？
ワニ？
(笑)
何人よ？（ワニ）
どうした？ どうしたんすか？
待ちなさい！
はじめ！ 待ちなさい
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
\ゴーーーンッ/
ワーーッ‼︎
アーーッ！
アイッ！ アイッ！ アイッ！ブルベリアイ
アッ…ぁ〜///
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会２位のサウンド）
あ〜 疲れたな〜
\パンツ/
うっは は〜ぃ え〜ぃ
も〜〜ぅ
(笑) (笑) (笑)
ワニッ？
\パンッ/
ウッ アッ〜ォ
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
イヤッ ハッ！
\パーンッ/
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
【雑談中】
\ウワーーッ！/（ワニ）
ワーーッ‼︎‼︎
ふょるるん（口笛世界大会ギリギリ１位のサウンド）
\プォーンッ！/
ヒ〜ッ‼︎
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
\ウワーーッ‼︎/（ワニ）
ワッ！ ワニ？ エッ？
\ワーーッ‼︎/（ワニ）
うわぁーッ‼︎（ワニ）
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
\ヴゥーーッ‼︎/（ワニ）
ワーーッ‼︎（ワニ）
ドタっ
♫ 〜エンディング〜 ♪
ふょるるるんｎ（口笛世界大会１位のサウンド）
\プォーンッ‼︎/
ア〜ッ！ ウッ！ イッ！
イッ イッ イッ
アッ アッ ア〜ハ〜アーン///
ア〜
\プォーンッ！/
ア〜 ア〜
(笑)
なんで アベック（ワニ） が出た？  (笑)